them on these for nonsense reasons this
is a cancer of the um unfortunately that
we have to you know ignore and uh
basically make them distinct because
they're working against the interests of
the umah under this guise of quote
unquote anyway before respect to you and
can I just say the reason I asked you
you will say Okay I I I said very
clearly I want to hear your perspective
because now we have around the world
Muslims who are influential right
Muslims who have a voice in which a lot
of people are listening to them getting
guidance from them or suggestions from
them so we need to know you know in
terms of different perspectives that are
around we hear these perspectives we
analyze them critically and see which is
something that we can benefit from if
there's something if for example danu
gave an advice which is against the
Quran and Sunnah Muslims will know that
this is not correct and they will leave
it but if there is something that is
based on the Quran and Sunnah then we
should take that advice and say no doubt
yeah even from a CF if you say the truth
yeah but we we're not interest the C's
opinion no but I'm saying even if a c is
true so that's why that's why I ask
Daniel because I know like yourself
there are many du who are influential so
if Muslim lay people like myself can
learn from all of you and we can have
directions and suggestion I think this
would be better for our Muslim um and at
this stage what I feel that we need to
understand okay we have differences but
we need to somehow leave these
differences for another time when
Muslims are in need to unite and at
least we can United for our common goal
I mean if you if I'm wrong you can
correct me a common goal against Zionist
entity and its endorsers and supporters
who are making the Mickey out of the
Muslim nations and the Muslim Community
worldwide so how can we with this
different perspective your
perspective your perspective then we can
work together and look at how we can
change the um of course the change needs
to happen with our own selves first but
we need to know how this can
change Amer
uned every time speak someone behind
Okay
firstly first
first is wrong to ask me or ask because
in the Quran as you know in the Quran as
you know Allah
said Allah told us in a time of
calamities and U and trials and
tribulations we don't go back to
influences we go back to the the the
schols and the leaders not to the
influences that is I respect you now I
respect
you to ask him or ask me even me is a
big mistake and that's what's happening
to the um now the um the scholars I mean
albani they will ask about when there
was there's a they ask should we Unite
with other groups for the sake of the
greater benefit all of them Al said no
fan said no said no what does it mean
I'm not saying imagine now all of us who
are Muslims yeah okay if Z is coming to
attack us I'm not going to say where's
your no now he defend you know even said
now if there are greater enemy okay they
have greater weapons and we know if we
do fight them they're going to kill us
all and there's a way to escape we can
escape and prepare ourselves to come
back but if there's no way for us to
escape even fight with the stones with a
knife with a spoon
because so the point respect this is not
the
way
when passed away the left OM they start
listening to who the SC has mentioned
even though is from the major of the
butak is bigger than him so in a ask me
him to begin with and
uniting AA issue is the most important
thing no doubt but I'm not speaking
about if enemy coming to attack us now I
have to check his AA no he a time to
fight now you understand so the point
here is I respect to all of you this
brother has been lying slandering Us
online and I I have I have showed him
and instead of he
said support your brother either is
oppressor who the one who been oppressed
they say oh messenger of Allah if he's
been oppressed we know how it is but
what about the
oppress from
oppress have a simple question for the
audience can Muslims normalize relations
with Israel yes or no no can can Muslim
normaliz relations with Israel yes
everyone can Muslims normalize relations
with everyone said noof are they proof
or proof no yes or no this the
proof can Muslims normalize
relations Muslims normalize relations
with Israel yes or no yes or no yes or
no answer yes or no simple no wait wait
wait give me simple no can I speak can I
speak yes this is Despicable he cannot
say a simple no he cannot say no this is
disgusting how can we talk to this
how how wife how many condemn Israel how
many can you condemn
Israel can you condemn normalization
Israel all the time
because don't run don't run don't run
you see what he's doing he asking the
people's asking the question agre with
the beginning of your you said in times
of difficulty
wait no no has wait brother are they
approv I asked you I'm asking you are
they appr answer my question answer my
question Brothers Brothers
Brothers normaliz wait wait wait let me
speak now let me speak don't put
pressure on me like this okay let me
normalize with Israel yes or no let me
speak let me speak let me speak now yes
or no
why can't you say no this is
disgusting our Palestinian brothers and
sisters are being killed and you can't
answer question can we normalize can
Muslims normalize
relations yes or no
I'm
me according to Quran Sunnah out of
necessity as a said out of extreme
necessity yes
not alive today now now if a Muslim wait
let me finish let me finish let me
finish we don't with these Zion
supporters you want to normalize you
want to normalize relationship
youlim
Muslims can normalize relations I didn't
say that no no I
said listen listen carefully to I said
out of extreme necessity meaning that if
the Muslim they are being oppressed okay
and they believe by doing don't use
normalization use a peace treaty that's
the Quran sunah normalization
normalization being done by the believe
that legitimizes the genocide of
Palestinian Muslims and brothers and
sisters anyway that's what normalization
means everyone here
knows Li what
normalization
anyway now who's yourse Danel the who
kill the sah or the Z who kill the
Muslims no
no okay why person treat with them
that's a that's a based on them not
killing anym sahab of was based on not
killing the country let me talk you talk
let me talk okay go on this is not a
peace treaty normalization means that
you he interrupts he interrupts Sor
Treaty of hudia is not the same as
normalizing relations with Israel
normalizing relations with Israel means
that these Muslim countries resume ties
economic ties with the terrorist State
while the Muslims are being killed at
the same time this is not a valid
agreement this is not a valid the
premise of this normalization of
relations with Israel is that the gazans
and in the West Bank the Palestinians
will continue to be boycotted they'll
continue to be blockaded they'll
continue to be ethnically cleansed until
they are completely wiped out that's
what normalization
means this is not a this is not
a so tell me I asked you about
normalization when you say normalization
are you talking about embassies in the G
countries is that what he economic TI
normalization economic relations
diplomacy all that's all under
normaliz legitimizing the terrorist
state of Israel saying
it's maybe talking CR understand because
he he clearly said that he he opposes a
Zionist but in in the state when want
normalizations with let me finish let me
finish let me finish let me not talk so
why didn't you answer his question about
noral
before that I mention correct he said
the on a condition they not kill Muslims
but is it not condition they will if a
Muslim if a Muslim becomes a and he runs
to ofr and will torture him person
accept that condition or not he did he
did know
these wa no no M let finish
m
respect I
Haven you know why angry because he was
speak let me
speak the treat of hudia Imagine now a
Muslim country make peace treaty with a
CF country and a c country say listen on
a condition if a Muslim runs away from
us and he comes to you you have to give
him up to us and by giving him up to us
we will torture him if a Muslim country
would do that are they
Muslim people ask answer answer okay
okay Muslim what happened no no no no
what happened happen let me finish let
me finish you have to
finish let me finish
all of us all of
us all of us we the all of let me finish
let me
finish we let him
finish treaty PE treat one of the
condition that the Muslims they will be
tortured tortured imagine and one of the
other
a a Muslim becomes if a Muslim becomes a
and he runs to don't have to give him to
the Muslims they don't have to give him
up but if a Muslim runs away and he
becomes a
Mor
sorry if
someone runs away and becomes a Muslim
they have to give him back okay and they
will torture him all right the point
here is that we have talk about peace
treaty if this no let me finish peace
treat peace treaty for example clearly
said in order for us to have peace
treaty with you in a condition thate has
to have its right that's the condition
no I don't know Abu what right what's
the right their right to exist their
country what country they don't have a
country
it what I'm saying I'm saying the one I
accept the one they're going to give a
right to Palestinians and they should
protect them that's the one yeah that's
that's what theist want too you're on
the same page with the protect the
Muslims
the Zionist also
want muhamed online he said there has no
problem with two State solution I reject
there only one Palestine that so
normalization doesn't accept that wait
islamically now if they make peace
treaty that's between the me I accept
nothing it's
not why
you why
you Bally and normalization are two
different things I yes I believe
normalization if they no no if they say
normalization mean that okay we're going
to just have treaty you kill the Muslims
and everything do whatever you like
that's
nonsense no no it's not it's not because
I'm when they want
to way thei and Jordan the and Jordan in
Egypt they have agreed on something even
though they said the only way that the
palestin they have the right to have
their their own country so that's and
one of the things as well part of the
things even about the alization by the
way that now nowadays for example if
there is no peace treaty between Jordan
and and Israel for example nowadays
there will there is no soal the occupied
palese and Egypt there is no Aid will
receive to Gaza no Aid no any no no a to
come from Jordan to there there they
can't send medication they can't send
food and because of this peace treaty so
this the leaders of the Muslims they
have appointed certain things in order
for them to make sure that at least they
can that the
[Laughter]
aid
understand
understand no no because I want
speaking it you
treat
issues made
m
askl i just as a very simple
question I'll ask you again my question
Muslims normalize with the terror of
Israel is from Islam
do you think do you
think yeah they're absolutely different
okay but you agree you agree with that
right guys are talking wait wait so back
I support kill the
Muslim you said you do accept
normalization just like you it me yes
Len he's saying they're different that's
what I'm
saying that's why people speaking listen
what I'm going to say yes brother
this mization yeah this is a term was
not used by so we stick with the Quran
with the what is peace treaty agree with
him no wait wait saying
normal no that's okay so accept so do
you accept sometimes you can do peace
treaty with the
Zionist them even one of the condition
they will torture the Muslims what do
you mean when he said no by the way by
the
way let him talk because he said
no because that was clearly peace treaty
between between the Jews and and the
Muslims at that
time brother brother Daniel when we say
no that means this is an Islamic ruling
it should base on on
something let him elaborate that's what
that's
what the Zionist state takes it for
granted that Palestinians are going to
be ethnically cleansed that they're
going to be exp uh expelled their land
that they're going to be genocided that
is the entire premise of the Zionist
State it's not like another cfir state
it's different when it's Zionism that's
an ideology that calls for clearing the
land of Palestinians it's not just any
cfir state so a treaty with them is not
allowed because of this they are in
Perpetual war against Muslims it is
completely different than the qur who
said that we were not we're not going to
attack this is different than the
Zionist State when the Zionist State
makes a treaty with one of these Muslim
countries the country is acknowledging
that zionists will continue to expand
their settlements they will continue
to that's what they're doing that's why
that's
why don't interrupt me so pro pro yeah
I'll give you the proof I'll give you
the the Jordan when he made peace treaty
with is that same condition to wipe out
give us the I'll give you the proof when
after many of these countries I won't
name them they normalized with Israel
what is Netanyahu showing to the United
Nations when he shows a map of Israel no
Gaza in that map no West Bank in that
map what does that mean they don't
acknowledge the Palestinians okay that
means they want to wipe them out that is
their ideology that is their policy yet
you have traitors who are stabbing our
brothers and sisters in the back by
signing normal ization agreements this
is completely this is completely
treachery
against you are
supporting ly against
me not even a verse no no wait wait wait
wait wait first firstly you claim that
we in the Muslim countries have peace
treaty with the Zionist that they accept
one of the condition to expend okay
that's not true show us one show us with
the Jordanian in Israel they sign one of
the condition that yes the making
up and by the way I came from family
which we are aware of all of the these
details basically that the agreement
that to have the two State country
that's the agreement between known he
lies treat M that's a
treat now what
happen let finish the problem is the
problem is we need to understand about
our our our our power ourselves as
Muslims and before that our Dean you
know the Arabs all the Arabs in the in
the 1960 in the 1967 they you know what
they used to say they said the time for
the fish to starve in the sea we're
going to throw the all the these
dinosaur in the sea because they unite
all of them Arabs even there is two pan
great pan came from Iraq to to Jordan
three pans came from Saudi Arabia Saudi
Army came to Jordan and all of them they
came what's what was they all of them
unied under what under what under Arab
Arab Flags it's about Islam not Islam
was what happened all of them they were
defeated so anything which as to
say so that's why if we wanted Allah to
give us the victory on Earth we have to
Allah says in the Quran this is the of
Allah Allah
stated if you supported Allah Allah will
support you and Allah will will give you
firm firmness on the on the land and
that's why even when the Muslims were
defeated Islam was Victorious was why
because Allah this is the of Allah as
long as the
Muslims as long as the Muslims they
unite upon Islam they unite upon Islam
as as as the Muslims they follow Islam
then Allah will give them the Victory
and as soon as they are away from that
Allah will destroy them this muham one
second yeah you have to Fe Allah because
he knows the ways and the condition and
we know the condition with the Muslim
count when they made peace treaty yes me
personally me me according to me I don't
accept none of this I don't believe
sorry sorry but we're talking about you
don't agree with what I don't agree with
this stuff you don't agree with the
countries making Tre me
personally condemn the countries let me
finish the rulers made let me finish I'm
not talking about my desires but now is
my desire the criteria or is a criteria
if Quran is a criteria then I have to go
and guess my desires and accept the Quan
that's what I'm doing alhamdulillah but
you standing here you your desire to
condemn no no no no Noah he tell us out
of necessity you love to have a peace
treaty you just let me let me finish you
just lied here that you said the Muslim
countries signed a peace treaty and the
condition is the the Israeli to expend
day Authority that's not true all the
country let me
finish
anyway anyway the peace treaty of the
Muslim countries the peace treaty of the
Muslim countries either is the the two
State solution
dise I'm saying two
Sol wait wait
wait you're talking about like years not
clearly
said by officially officially Saab they
said the only way that will there will
be treaty between Saudi Arabia and and
and
isra ISS issue this
issue this issue of peace treaty this
issue of har and Salam is it for the
Layman here or for the scholars and the
leaders obviously the schols that's so
take it back for asking the
people
thatal all of the schols around all of
them all of
them breaking
it you know they were not supposed to
they all
no I tell
you let me finish can we can we TR some
who doesn't respect treaties can we
respect wa wait he's asking a question
has asking a question
answer any the brother see you know the
problem when people cut you and many
people speak sometimes things is been
mentioned without any clarification okay
to the nation so the point here is that
we have to take it back the point here
that he was wrong for asking a Muslim
lay man maybe some of doesn't ever know
the difference between a pillar and and
a condition of prayer but yet he's
speaking about big issues look at the
slander that you're making why do you
say that these Muslims don't know how to
PR let finish let me finish let me
finish say that let me finish brother he
with you what is it I'm here I'm
here and condition of Prayer my
question Em
emal I'm Liar Liar this
Li Allah us clearly in the Quran Allah
told us clearly in the Quran he he
didn't even one verse of Allah said
what you
say if they turn it back to Allah Allah
messenger and the leaders and the
scholars Allah
musim answer my question my question was
if some some
entity list listen if some entity like
the Occupy like like the Israel if they
keep breaking treaties should we
continue making treaties with them
because they did not respect
resolution he had the power to do it
have the have the power
last question
last ask good question he asked good
question I asked good question he asked
he asked good question he said if we
having this like the z c them
sayal
relations Muslim that's
why
actional watch my
video
normalization show me the video show me
show me yeah show
me let me speak and
show he I said all mus he's you said it
never said going to bring
by the way by the way
way all of us all
of way resp let me finish
resp he said he said yeah hash asked can
we keep peace treaty with the people
that keep breaking it muhamad Mak a good
point that's not for me that's it goes
back to the schor and the leaders
because they look at it they look have
you asked them have you ask I'm here
you you li take
back are you going to take back the can
I say something take this back let me
show you
can I can I say something yeah while
he's fighting you can say yeah yeah if
okay Saudi rulers the UAE rulers they
say that Muslims need to pledge
allegiance to the Zionist States yeah
can Muslims here criticize that decision
I reject it I would reject it yeah we
can criticize them you can't the
decision we can criticize the rulers I
don't think can we criticize the rulers
if they say we should all pledge
allegiance to Zionism Zion I don't
believe that is non sense can we condemn
the yes cond they say be Muslim does
make
sense answer the question I said no I
said I condemn them you condemn the
ruler their political decision they tell
me I have to to Z you can be Muslim be
the same they never say that they never
say that no if they
say Cur them and Destroy
them
man
wait no no no no no no no wait wait wait
wait wait
wait because this is exactly what these
countries are doing they're saying that
Muslims to have this peaceful relation
while
Muslim he's a
liar he agreed to condemn
that I think we should let's
R I
said wait no no wait wait no no wait
wait wait he again he said he said he
said
doing change topic he change the topic
again listen listen listen he said to me
if
let me finish I'm going to him just give
me two minutes please yeah he said to me
IFI orat say I have to give allegiance
to the zist
accept Okay let me finish let me finish
let me finish don't change
me you're Muslim you have
toally and econom you Chang
let me finish let me finish Daniel let
me finish
I'm let me
finish and
economically let me
finishing
me he said he said to me he's let me
finish my
word I will give you let me finish he
said I'm going to call him word for word
he said to me if Sai and Emirates they
to give allegiance to the Muslims to the
Zionist you know EC let meish let me
finish let me finish to the zist no I
didn't
say politically and economically when
did I say ba what does that mean it
means politically economically they
agree in terms I have to accept them to
serve them
yeah you
CRI IDE
because let finish
see what they do bring many
me
you you don't let me finish every
finish made let him finish let him
finish let him
finish come down down come down first of
all seriously first of all come down
that's you I'm I'm going to come that's
the problem problem problem anyway I
want to him I want to cut him word for
word word for
he said to me would you give Allegiance
would you accept to Saudi tell you to
give Allegiance a political econom
economy initially you didn't say
political I hear this
now
finish please then he goes on to say I
said no accept that he goes on to say
that's what the are doing are Allegiance
I said that is not true is a lie never
said to every Muslim give algi to the KU
then he Chang it he said economically
and politically if if the Muslim
countries believe the mic dropped if the
Muslim leaders yes believe it's for
their best interest to have a peace
treaty with a Zionist which will benefit
the Palestinians first and the people
yes then it goes back to schol and the
leaders and now to criticize them
Prophet Muhammad
said messenger of Allah listen to this
oh messenger of Allah how should we deal
with the leaders they
take they will not give our rights and
they take their right from us our rights
they will not give it to us imagine your
right my right they say no you're not
going to get take your right but they
will take their right from you what
should we do he said he and
obey and hear and obey to this man who
are because okay so
if take it
back EST
before no no before before he listen to
you listen to him no problem but before
that what we
doing let me respond before that we
cannot just leave it you have to leave
it after you said you mischaracterize
what I said he
Saye please Daniel try to use kind of
speci try to be try to be specific in
terms of because I understood when you
said Allegiance I
underst I don't think anyone
else listen to my defition
normalization
we no but has to take back the light
that he
said go the speaker these rulers are
telling Muslims around the world we
don't have B to these rulers I'm not
under the allegiance of these rulers but
they say every Muslim around the world
should pay Allegiance economically uh
diplomatically politically to the
Zionist State imagine this is a imagine
imag he
cannot he
cannot so what so I said love these
rulers are saying pay Allegiance
notes
it
do Muslims have to obey do can Muslims
criticize this decision he's saying no
you cannot because it's not what is
the I you you gave me a about those who
are under the